be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so as we continue
our discussion on Jonathan Hickman's
fantastic for instead of writing out a
script for this what I want to do is
have fun with it a script is usually a
good idea if it's something like the
little documentary thing that I'm doing
for a history of the Marvel Universe
but I think with a story like this that
I absolutely love I think it's easier to
just sort of run through it kind of off
the cuff so in the previous video that I
had done on this we had talked about how
following the events of Civil War Reed
Richards had basically come to this
realization that it was inevitable that
humanity would destroy itself and so
because he was effectively the smartest
person in the world he had basically
taken it upon himself to solve the
problem of everything
now while Hickman doesn't directly give
it to us what he tells us is that
somewhere along the line Reed had
developed a multi-dimensional bridge
meaning he could access other dimensions
and other universes and that after he
had done this he had begun speaking with
disembodied voices but didn't really
know who he was talking to but after
getting in and talking to those
individuals he basically discovered they
were alternate reality versions of
himself who had come together to form
something called the Council of reeds
which is basically an amalgamation of
all these different versions of Reed
Richards who had all come together to
solve the problem of everything now
we're the first video covered how we
were given a tour of these different
realities and the different steps that
were taken to solve the problem of
everything
what Hickman does in this comic here in
issue number 572 is basically show us
how much hubris the council has and what
I mean here is that we're Huber's is
basically just excessive pride or
extreme arrogance what Hickman's telling
us is that because all these different
versions of Reed Richards had taken it
upon themselves to solve the problem of
everything they effectively saw
themselves as fixtures everything was
within their ability to fix but with
these Celestials that appear from the
earth for to 8/0 reality we learn that's
not the case now in the last video we
had talked about how these Celestials
hailed from a universe where they had
gone mad with power instead of just
being explorers and chroniclers of
science and technology like in the
current Marvel Universe they had come to
the conclusion that because they were so
powerful they should rule that universe
the mad Celestials that come together
and wiped out that universes version of
eternity and the other cosmic entities
and then force the inhabitants of that
universe to begin worshipping the
Celestials and so while one of these
versions of read was housed within that
reality and exploring he had stumbled
across the Celestials and in turn the
Celestials basically took apart his mind
read his thoughts and discovered the
existence of the council and looked to
use the various dimensional portals of
this Council of reeds to access other
realities and essentially take over the
multiverse and so what this does is this
picks up with those particular series of
events and it shows us that the
Celestials
are essentially laying waste to everyone
and what I mean is that none of these
reads stand a chance now this is very
very important here and the reason why
this is a big deal is because while
these reads are running for weapons and
different things like that one of the
first questions we would ask is that if
three of these reads have infinity
gauntlets why can't they use them well
like we saw in the last video the
Infinity Gauntlet scan only be used in
the reality that they hail from and
because the Council of reads is located
in this place outside of all time and
space the gauntlets don't natively work
there and so what happens is that one of
the Reed Richards who has an Infinity
Gauntlet speaks to another version of
Reed whose body is essentially a portal
to his native dimension and so the reed
with the Infinity Gauntlet sticks his
hand into the portal which basically
allows him to just dip his toe so to
speak into his own reality and by virtue
of that use the Infinity Gauntlet but
what's really funny about this is that
it still doesn't work because the mad
Celestials appear to be so powerful
whether it's because they evolved
differently or they absorb other
individuals is it made clear but because
the power that they possess
even if only a handful or wiped out more
just keep coming
now what Hickman is indirectly telling
us is that because the Celestials in the
main Marvel Universe exist by way of
literally planting their seeds in
planets and then allowing the Celestials
to emerge in those planets Galactus was
most likely destroyed when the mad
Celestials took over meaning there was
no one to consume the planets to keep
the Celestials from being born and so
the result is that these Celestials most
likely took over the reality not in just
power but in sheer population and so
what the mad Celestials laying waste to
the council and the main
earth-616 Reed Richards making his
escape he travels back to the Baxter
building closes the portal barely making
it out alive and begins grabbing up
different arms and armament now what I
want to do here is I want to sidetrack
away from what Reed Richards is doing
for a second and I want to focus on
Franklin and valaria now this is not
wildly important for the events that are
transpiring with the MADD Celestials but
it will be important later on and the
reason why is because all of this is
basically about Franklin Richards the
entirety of Hickman's run is literally
about Franklin Richards I know it
doesn't seem like it now but as we get
further into this and we start seeing
Franklin Richards from the future we'll
begin to see just how important these
events are to his character and so what
we're basically seeing is Franklin and
valaria just kind of enjoying themselves
messing around with the different
artifacts around the Baxter building now
for those of you guys who are not
familiar valaria is a character who is
wildly intelligent in fact she's about
as intelligent as both Reed Richards and
dr. doom despite the fact that she's
just a child and of course Franklin
Richards has the power to work reality
but something that I want you guys to
take note of here is that in this story
and within this point in Marvel's
timeline Franklin Richards had already
lost his powers they had been burned out
and they had been since the original
Abraxas saga when he resurrected
Galactus and destroyed Abraxas now if
you guys are interested we can have a
discussion on that at some future point
in time but all we really need to know
is that at this point in the story
Franklin cannot work reality you really
can't do anything he's effectively just
a normal boy now at this point we go
back to Reed Richards as he's gathering
different arms and armament together and
we actually pick up with Susan storm now
again this element of Susan and the
element of Franklin and valaria is going
to be important in the next couple pages
and the reason for this is that in the
previous events in the last video we had
talked about how Susan and Reed had had
some bit of a falling out and this was
due to the fact that Reed was just
constantly preoccupied he basically
wasn't paying attention to his family
and within Marvel comics the Susan storm
is very family-oriented she's
effectively the person that seems to be
holding everything together and so from
her perspective because Reed seems so
isolated and so removed from her and the
children as well as Johnny Storm and Ben
Grimm it seems as though Reed doesn't
care about them
now the reason why this is important is
because as we transition back to the
Council of reeds with Reed Richards
traveling back to try to get everybody
all the arms they need to defeat the
Celestials while they are successful in
doing this once the conflict is over we
end up finding out there's a much darker
side to the Council of reeds and what I
mean here is that in addition to the
council going through and essentially
lobotomizing all these different
versions of dr. doom who would display
to evil that just simply couldn't be
corrected we also learned that these
versions of Reed had all given up their
families from the dimensions that they
hail from in order to solve the problem
of everything it requires the totality
of their mind and the totality of their
focus and the result was that they
basically abandoned their families now
this point right here is the entire crux
of this story and this is why the end
result of everything is so important and
so if there's nothing else that you
remember from the story please remember
this one thing but the way that we learn
this is that with a version of Reed
Richards who had accidentally run into
the Matt Celestials and initiated this
entire conflict in the first place his
conversation with the main earth-616
version of Reed tells us that as time
progressed as they began to move away as
you spend less and less time with his
family
Susan storm from his reality began to
get angry and eventually walked away
from him
the children Franklin Richards and
valaria Richards did the same thing
Johnny Storm Ben Grimm it was all the
same process in addition to this that
reality's version of Captain America the
Avengers all the earth superheroes
slowly began to forget about Reed
Richards to the point that he didn't
exist or people didn't know who he was
and so even if you were to go back they
probably wouldn't recall him with the
exception of his closest family members
who probably wouldn't want to have
anything to do with him and so when the
earth-616 version of Reed is confronted
with this information he immediately
says no he says absolutely not there's
no way he's going to abandon his family
for the sake of trying to solve the
problem of everything because for him
it's too important now again this is
wildly important this is very very
significant this this these first few
issues are really the foundation for
everything which is why I keep stressing
how important they are now the reason
why Reed Richards chose to stay with his
family is explained to us when we get
another flashback with its father
Nathanael
now this is actually a point that's kind
of been dipped on occasionally over the
course of Marvel Comics but not really
on the previous video we had talked
about how Nathaniel Richards the father
of read was basically absentee
throughout his childhood while there
were moments where Nathaniel Richards
had travelled and appeared and made his
presence known to Reed Richards and even
engaged with him a little while for the
most part Reed
grew up without a dad and the result is
that he knows how it feels to not have a
father and so for him to be given the
option or to be told that he has to do
the same thing his father did and
abandoned his family in order to solve
the problem of everything for him it
just doesn't work he can't square that
circle and so what we find is that he
begins to reflect on his experiences of
a Ben Grimm and Johnny Storm his love
for Susan storm but he also keeps the
advice that his father gave him to be a
better man than he was to be a better
father to be a better husband and so
once Reed comes to this realization he
effectively steps out of his office and
begins to reconnect with Susan storm
well that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end
we're gonna wrap things up and what
we'll actually find in the next video is
that the Fantastic Four from Hickman's
run it's actually going to start tying
into other events and while a lot of
this isn't wildly important we're going
to go ahead and cover it anyway just
because there's a few things that pop up
here and there there are again going to
contribute to the larger story and
towards the end events regarding the
adult version of Franklin Richards
returning to the past with that being
said I will catch you guys later please